[Musique]
au quai site bonne nouvelle aux gens je
m'en fiche
pourquoi tu appelles maman elle sera en
uniforme pour clinton est arrivée
aujourd'hui il est vraiment très jolie
il a déjà un look intelligent comment
vous trouvez mon petit j'ai essayé un
nouveau mélange des pistes ou prêts nous
a trompés pour la plupart des espèces
mammifères la survie dépend de
l'appartenance à un groupe et de la
connaissance de ce groupe arrête de
t'asseoir comme si j'étais un oeuf suis
pas un oeuf lait les membres de mon
groupe ne cesse de migrer vers d'autres
écoles vitesse est en baisse leur une
chance
salut moi c'est qu'ici je m'en faut
faire d'autres maisons toi qui a lancé
une grenade dans nos vies ne peut plus
vivre avec toi ou juste loin de moi
c'est un mystère certaines choses
semblent solides comme le roc et se
fissure béante
avant même de temps un recompte tu es
tellement au fond du trou que c'est
quasiment impossible de creuser pour en
sortir qui s'y trouve que c'est
difficile de faire face au changement
mais il ya toujours un moyen de sortie
ça va pas être facile mais tu peux gérer
ça génère que tout ça on avait postulé
dans aucune université mais je dois
choisir une université fort tard est
écouté les autres tu veux quoi toi tu
sais tout le monde connaît des défaites
tu n'as pas le droit d'être ici à battre
par un échec c'est temporaire juste le
temps qu'on trouve une solution
j'ai utilisé mes réductions d'emploi y
est pour t'acheter ses crayons de papier
n'était pas obligé je suis ton grand
frère
moi aussi je peux être là pour toi
parfois
tu verras en prendre pour d'horribles
par an
vous êtes juste vous avez juste des gens
[Musique]
monde et brutale ladder c'est pour ça
qu'on a besoin de sa famille
je suis content qu'on sent suffisamment
en confiance pour faire ça de temps en
temps je n'ai pas d'avis sur le sujet
[Musique]